Want to spoil your girlfriend with diamonds
while impressing her with your scientific
knowledge.
Here's how:
Baby, we've been together a long time
and I've picked up on your hints -- I know
that you want a diamond,
but I was thinking
you're too special to me for just one diamond.
I want to give you one and a half million
diamonds...
per second.
And not only that, they're nanodiamonds.
really?
Yeah, isn't that great?
Nanodiamonds.
You are a fu-
Now is the perfect time to tell her scientists
have recently discovered nanodiamonds in the
flames of ordinary candles -- millions of
them!
As the hydrocarbon wax is burned tiny diamonds
form in the middle of the flame.
What?
They're the exact same as regular diamonds,
just really, really small.
You always told me size doesn't matter.
Are you packing?
I should have listened to my mother.
Actually, as it turns out, the nanodiamonds
are burnt up in the flame and released into
the atmosphere as carbon dioxide.
So you're better off getting a big diamond.
Otherwise your relationship, like the nanodiamonds,
will go up in smoke.